تفاعل رواد السوشيال ميديا اليوم حول
اللقاء الذي سيجمع اخوان لابورتا رئيس
برشلونه مع الارجنتيني ليونيل ميسي غدا
الاثنين خلال حفل الافضل الذي ينظمه
الاتحاد الدولي لكره القدم اخبار عديده
انتشرت من بينها قرب عوده ميسي لصفوف
القلعه الكاتالونيه خاصه بعد اجتماع
لابورتا مع والد البرغوث في الوقت الذي لم
يجدد فيه ليو عقده مع ناديه باريس سان
جيرمان الفرنسي والذي ينتهي في يونيو
المقبل من جانب اخر اكدت وسائل اعلام
فرنسيه
الانتقال للعيش في الولايات المتحده
واقتراب اللاعب الارجنتيني من اللعب في
الدوري الامريكي
نبقى مع اخبار برشلونه حيث خرج ريال مدريد
عن صمته في قضيه الرشوه المثاره حول غريمه
الكاتولوني والخاصه بالنائب السابق لرئيسه
لجنه الحكام في الدوري الاسباني لمليانو
مدير العلاقات المؤسسيه في ريال مدريد خرج
ليعلق اخيرا في على القضيه في تصريحات
نشرتها صحيفه ماركا الاسبانيه اوضح فيها
بان النادي الملكي لن يقوم باي فعل رسمي
او خلف الكواليس وعندما سينتظر لتاخذ
العداله مجراها بالنظر الى ان الريال ليس
الفريق الوحيد المتضرر على حد قوله
ننتقل الى انجلترا حيث شاهدت الساعات
القليله الماضيه اول اجتماع بين اللاعب
جرينويد واداره مانشستر يونايتد في اطار
تحقيق داخلي هذه الاجتماعات تهدف لحسم
قرار عوده المهاجم الانجليزي الى تدريبات
الفريق من عدمها بعد اسقاط جميع التهم
الخاصه بالاعتداء والاغتصاب التي وجهت
اليه واكدت الانباء الصحفيه ان هنالك
انقسام بين لاعبي الشياطين الحمر حول عوده
غنوه حيث ابدى البعض قلقه من استقرار
الفريق بعد عودته المحتمله الى جانب
ابتعاد الفريق النسائي من ذلك مما يعني
بحسب المنشور ان البته في القرار النهائي
لن يحسم حتى الصيف المقبل
صدفه خير من الف ميعاد قد يكون هذا هو حال
لورس كاريوس حارس نيوكاس الانجليزي
والمغني جاستن بيبر حيث تجمعهما علاقه
الصداقه قويه سببها وشم او ما يعرف
بالتاتو القصه تعود لصيف عام 2016 في فندق
ميامي حيث ابدى اعجابه بوشم للحارس الدولي
الالماني الذي قام بتزويده بجميع التفاصيل
الخاصه به من بعد ذلك من بعد تلك الحادثه
استمر الاتصال بينهما حتى ان بعض التقارير
الصحفيه اشارت الى ان جاستن بيبر قام
بالغاء بعض من جولاته الموسيقيه العالميه
من اجل حضور مباراه صديقه مع فريق نيوكاسل
ودعمه شخصيا في نهائي كاس الرابطه